the apps and games that are at the top
of the grossing charts on any of the
different platform stores are generally
using IPS in order to drive that revenue
that's where the bulk of it's coming
from and there's a couple key things
that they keep in mind when they're due
when they app developers are determining
which IPS they should offer and how to
price them first and foremost when
choosing which items to offer as in-app
purchases you have to make sure that the
items are content that enriches the game
I wouldn't rely on just having something
that prevents ads from being shown or
maybe just one or two variations in
graphics or things like that it has to
really be something that stands out and
take somebody who may have never paid
and turns them into a paying user there
are a few different forms of AI ApS the
first are content so if you want to
offer new items perhaps new maps if it's
a game that falls under content the
second is functionality so if there's a
different way to use your app or game
perhaps a different mode perhaps you
want to unlock different weapons that
might dramatically change the gameplay
experience that would fall under
functionality there are also services so
if you're building an app or game where
there are services that you need to
offer that aren't necessarily something
that you can do really quickly within
the game itself perhaps there's a
superior level of support if you're
offering an app that's a little bit more
sophisticated that's another type of IEP
that you can offer
finally there's subscriptions if you're
really an app that functions bit more
like a magazine or a game that requires
a multiplayer subscription in order to
connect online this is where
subscriptions lie they're probably the
least popular just because the use cases
are a little bit more limited but
they're no less valuable than any of the
other types of IPs that you can
offer so I ApS can be consumable use
them once and that's it they can be non
consumable so something like an
additional map pack that somebody should
always have access to is a non
consumable there are different types of
subscriptions that you can offer you can
offer us free subscription an auto
renewing subscription a non renewing
subscription and it really depends on
what you think people are most likely to
purchase and all of this can be tested
so you don't have to determine right off
the bat how this is going to go when
you're selecting IPS it's important to
select a wide range of price points
anything from the lowest up to the
highest somebody will always buy
whatever that highest point I a P is and
there's no reason to prevent yourself
from getting that revenue even if it
might seem a little absurd that somebody
wants to spend $99 on a coin pack there
will be somebody who inevitably wants to
spend $99 on a coin pack it's important
to offer that range all the way from the
lowest to the highest and then a good
mix in between Amazon generally
recommends at least 12 price points I
think that might be a little overkill
but somewhere in that neighborhood is
probably right finally for any of your
iips it's extremely important that the
non consumables can be restored we get a
lot of backlash from the platforms if
you have all of these IE PS that people
are purchasing yet they can't get them
back on their device you also see a
significant user backlash there which
won't be good in the long run